[Applause]
hello euro Jing's swipe and here's
what's coming up for you this week we've
got all the need-to-know highlights from
the world's largest phone show plus the
best games to play on mobile including a
pocket-sized game to fall in love with
and then put your phones down to see
Alex discover how artificial
intelligence is being used to tackle
poaching it's that time of year the week
when Tech's movers and shakers head to
the world's biggest phone show it means
we get to see how wireless devices will
impress us next so here's what's been
going on at Mobile World Congress in
Barcelona these are the crowds eager to
witness the latest round in a major
battle the Battle of the smartphone's
it's at this industry gathering that
some of the biggest mobile brands apart
from Apple announce new handsets and
tell us what we'll want to be carrying
around in our pockets over the next year
Samsung as expected made headlines early
on with its new Galaxy S nine featuring
improved cameras and a way to turn
selfies into a motor to the sa-2 an
uneducated consumer they'll look at it
and think it looks similar
so Samsung really needed to land some
key features like the camera like the
sound like the emojis and all those
things so make people realise that it is
a step up from the last model Nokia
announced five new phones including
another retro throwback a revamped 88 10
you remember that slider phone from the
90s Sony served up two new models with
cameras able to record in 4k
high-definition Huawei meanwhile showed
us the power and intelligence of its
phones by using one to drive a car
the company also launched a laptop and
tablet and its first 5g chip for mobile
devices while we're talking 5g and I'm
told we'll start seeing the wireless
technology in some
that's next year before a wider rollout
that should benefit us all 5g is trying
to build an infrastructure beyond just
handsets as we know them and what I mean
by that are connected devices Internet
of Things smart cities it's not just
phones at MWC you know any good tech
event has a multitude of gadgets
demonstrating technologies best boldest
and sometimes questionable uses coffee
decorated with your own selfie anyone
Internet of Things uses and biometrics a
hot topics here as is the buzz around
artificial intelligence smartphone
makers currently use AI for things like
personal assistants image recognition
and learning our habits but there's a
lot more to come the most impressive
thing about AI is we do not yet know
what AI is gonna do for us it's think
about the internet think about 1996 it's
that point with AI
so the key thing though is we're just
gonna have to make that shift between
being mobile first to AI first perhaps
the most well-known use of AI though
remains with robots these ones know how
to serve coffee teach coding and help
improve your posture surely it won't be
long now before your phone can do all
that too so given that this is the week
of the world's largest phone show
there's only one kind of game that we
want to feature in our games review
segment the kind you play on a handset
is gab with his picks Annapurna pictures
are a film release company that you
might know for films like phantom thread
zero dark thirty in her but they've
actually started releasing really really
good games in the last year or so one of
those games is gorgoa which is a puzzle
art game which you basically are
presented with a bunch of pictures like
really really lovely stuff as well for a
mobile game and you have to sort of
explore them and really really interact
with them to try and figure out what the
link is between them which advances the
story that you're doing now the themes
that the paintings cover are quite hefty
which you might not think it's good for
a mobile game but I think it's brilliant
because it's not just something that you
play passively it's something that
you're super into and you've really got
to put a lot
time into it two guests coming out of
village for a mobile game is actually
pretty good
Florence is another game from Annapurna
pictures it's basically a short story in
your pocket where you follow this girl
Florence
doing sort of menial tasks that's the
game bit where you're sort of like tap
in to put shoes away and things like
that and but then she meets someone and
you start dating them and then you start
doing these little sort of puzzles that
end up being your conversations with the
person if you think of it like a short
story where by the end you're gonna have
this massive connection to this
character that you didn't know before
I've never really felt like that playing
a game before because you know you you
read a short story on a Kindle you sort
of reader you do have a connection and
then you go where is this you're
actually playing through and you feel a
little bit more invested because of
these menial tasks you've helped her
with it's just brilliant death Road
character is more like a mobile game
that we kind of would want you've
basically got to get from Florida to
Canada which doesn't sound that hard
except the road is full of zombies
obviously it's kind of like an action
RPG where you interact with like these
weird little people on your way that
have been living their lives since the
saw somebody pockets kicked off and
they're all trying to either help you or
hinder you as you find your way to
Canada you find yourself pretty immersed
in it because the game stuff even though
it's quite basic it's really nice to
play and it just feels really intuitive
and you kind of really really get into
it and without realizing it you're
totally into the story as well which
sounds really simple but you know
getting from one place to another
pretty easy really
[Applause]
x-files deep state is almost a perfect
mobile game
it's this weird little mystery that is
based around the game element of finding
stuff you kind of given little clues on
the mystery that you're solving so you
might be in someone's house looking for
clues you're literally looking for clues
that's what you're doing and the timer
runs out so there's a weird sort of
urgency to it that you've got to keep an
eye on because obviously your points go
down the longer you take for it I'm sure
some people will absolutely love this I
found it quite frustrating but I did
really like the story element of it and
you interact with like Mulder and Scully
and other characters from the x-files
universe so that part I really really
liked actually looking for things and
looking for clues I'm rubbish out so
that's the best of what's been going on
in the world of mobile now here's a
quick look what else has been happening
in tech this week Amazon has bought a
company that makes doorbells which allow
you to see who's at the front door when
you're not home analysts see the deal
with ring reportedly worth over a
billion dollars as a sign that Amazon
wants to expand its home security
products and deliveries inside customers
homes British car maker Jaguar Land
Rover has showed us its first fully
electric vehicle the ipace runs on
lithium ion battery and can apparently
be charged to up to 80% in 45 minutes
integrated with the Alexa service a
driver will be able to ask the car
questions it'll set you back around 63
and a half thousand pounds though 4G
connectivity will soon be available on
the moon Vodafone Germany and Nokia are
working with privates
peaty scientists to create the first 4G
lunar network by next year online
scammers could buy your entire personal
identity for just eight hundred and
twenty pounds research by comparison
site top 10 VPN comm has also found that
dark web criminals can buy your passport
details for as little as forty pounds
music streaming service Spotify has
filed paperwork to sell shares publicly
on the New York Stock Exchange the firm
says the move could value the world's
biggest streaming service at around
twenty three billion dollars about 16
and a half billion pounds and crypto
jackin attacks in the UK have gone up by
1,200 percent in just a few months
researches of told Sky News crypto
jacking involves using someone else's
computer to mine cryptocurrencies we go
from tech and machines to animals now
because this week alex has been finding
out how artificial intelligence is being
used to help tackle animal poaching this
lots are curious bunch these Emperor
tamarin and red titi monkeys are just
some of the residents here at zsl London
Zoo and it doesn't take long for them to
spot the arrival of cameras in their
rainforest enclosure researchers here
have teamed up with Google using
artificial intelligence to monitor
critically endangered species and their
habitats and a spot poachers now the
center of all this conservation work are
these this is a camera trap effectively
a motion-triggered camera and this one
sends the information back to base via
mobile phone network and it's there that
the images of the animals are downloaded
before being uploaded to the cloud where
machine learning takes a look and
identifies the animals that this has
captured it takes a human hours if not
days to sift through all the images and
tag them when they're collected in the
wild Google's algorithm is now being
tasked with this project and it could
save time and money machine learning has
the potential to really speed up our
analysis of these images to help species
identification it also helps us detect
poachers in the field we can download
the algorithms to sit on the camera
traps themselves so they can detect
humans in the images in real time and
raise alerts of those in protected air
so that we can respond to those threats
but simply machine learning is a
practical application of artificial
intelligence by feeding images into this
algorithm the team have trained it to
recognize different species but there's
a catch
subtle variations can baffle even the
most complex and sophisticated
algorithms in a way that just simply
isn't the case with humans
in December a team in America fooled
Google's algorithm into thinking a
picture of skiers was a dog so can we
really trust machine learning as you
start creating more extensive and and
models which are trained on a much
larger datasets they actually start
becoming more resilient to changes in
pixels and so on and and being able to
be more accurate really so there's that
I think there's an aspect which is is
simply related to the quantity and the
depth of training if we to trust AI in
other areas like driverless cars the
risk from technical tricks has to be
addressed
so teaming up with conservationists and
training algorithms to recognize species
it's just one of the ways that machine
learning is being toughened up and
trained for new challenges in the future
Alex Morgan Sky News well that's it for
this week's show
join us again for more swype next week
and in the meantime follow us on Twitter
at Sky News wife bye bye
you
[Applause]
[Music]